we continue the conversation this
morning with senator harris she's with
us from miami
in her only network tv interview after
the debate senator good morning
good morning let me start but you said
last night that you do not believe
joe biden is a racist but do you think
that his remarks about
segregation as senators and his past
policy on busing
effectively disqualify him as a
candidate
no i think that's a decision for the
voters to make but he and i have a
disagreement obviously
on on the issue but no i think the
voters will decide
whether he is qualified to run or serve
senator harris you your campaign clearly
had an idea that this topic might come
up they had a picture ready they sent
out a tweet
from your perspective i'm curious to
know what do you hope voters
who may have been hearing about you for
the first time and hearing from you for
the first time
what should voters take away from that
exchange with joe biden
you know i mean the purpose and my
purpose in
in raising my experience is was
to really just make sure that in this
conversation
we are appreciating the impact on real
people of policies
um that have been pushed in in the
history of our country
um you know way back when and and the
effect even today
the point that i was making is had those
senators those segregationists had their
way
i would not be a member of the united
states senate today i would certainly
not be
a top contender to be president of the
united states
so the impact of their work was very
real and it is something that when we
are discussing an issue of race
has to be appreciated which is this is
not just an intellectual
or academic discussion um the history of
race in our country had a real
impact on real people senator harris we
just heard ed o'keefe say you're being
accused of delivering a low blow last
night what do you say to that
you know gail it was about just speaking
truth and
um as i've said many times i have a
great deal of respect for joe biden
he has served our country over many
years in a very noble way
but we and he and i disagree on that and
it is a debate
this is a campaign where we should be
discussing
issues and there will be contrast and on
this issue i
i suppose and i guess it's evident that
there is a contrast of opinion
on the significance of of people who
have served
in the united states senate and what
they have done in terms of their
policies
your performance last night is certainly
what people are talking about this
morning i'm hearing words like a star is
born
she is fervent but she is fervent but
deploys her anger precisely
like a flashlight voters in iowa new
hampshire are telling cbs news today
that you had a strong performance
how do you intend to capitalize on that
momentum clearly the t-shirts is one way
i understand that those are already on
sale
oh i don't i don't know about the
t-shirts i know we've got a little um
we visit conway.org i know we have a
shop but i'll say this gail i listen
from the beginning when we
entered the campaign um and i
it for me it's about working hard to
earn
the vote and and the support of of of
americans and so i will continue
to spend time in iowa and new hampshire
and south carolina nevada as the primary
states but
frankly throughout the country and i
will
hopefully listen as much if not more
than i talk especially now because
i will tell you i do intend to win this
election but for me
the mark of our success will also be
that i listen
um because really i think the the most
important thing is that at the end of
this
um that we are relevant and so my plan
is to keep
getting out there and speaking to folks
and listening to them and
and talking about my 3am agenda which is
what
i hope to do that is relevant to the the
concerns that people have when they wake
up at three o'clock in the morning
trying to figure out how to make it all
work senator vice president biden didn't
didn't see a change in his polling
numbers after
his remarks about segregation as
senators why even among black voters for
that matter why do you think that is
i mean i'll leave that to the pundits
but again i think that
this is an issue that is something that
should be discussed
in the context of everything that we
should remember about the history of our
country but
we should also be having discussions
about this election in the context of
what we need to do to go forward um my
campaign
certainly my perspective is not only
about speaking truth about the past but
also focusing on the future
and again that's why i talk about issues
like health care what we need to do to
pay teachers
their value what we need to do to pay
women equal for for the same work as men
what we need to do around gun violence
and and having smart gun safety laws
these are the issues that i am focused
on because these are the issues that
wake people up at three in the morning
and need to be addressed and we need
leadership on these issues
senator another defining moment in the
debate was when every candidate was
asked to raise their hand if they would
abolish
private insurance in that moment you
raised your hand
but afterwards your campaign says
actually that's not your position so
what is your position
on private insurance
so the question was would you be willing
to give up your private insurance that's
not how it was
such a plan and that's what you heard
right okay
yeah that's certainly what i heard and
um in terms of
i am supportive of medicare for all and
under medicare for all policy
private insurance would certainly exist
and for supplemental
coverage but under medicare for all and
my vision of it
we would actually extend benefits so for
example vision care dental care hearing
aids
which currently are not covered and
anyone you know who's a senior can tell
you they're extremely expensive and
people have to come out of pocket to pay
for them
included in my perspective on the issue
of private insurance is this
and i told the story last night look any
night in america
there is some parent who's got a child
who has a fever that's
out of control and going to the
emergency room
to get help at the middle of the night
and then looking at those sliding glass
doors as they're in their car in the
parking lot
concerned that if they walk through
those sliding glass doors
they're going to be out of pocket five
thousand dollars because of the
deductible they've got
insurance all right they will be out of
pocket five thousand dollars
we're going to have to leave it there so
you know 91
and i'll just add 91 percent of the
doctors in america today are in medicare
so you won't lose your doctor all right
senator harris you've had the last word
we thank you very much i'm sure we'll
talk to you a little bit i appreciate it
later on as this campaign continues
thank you for joining us this morning
absolutely thank you guys have a good
day
thank you